they focus they should agree insane
condition caused by the drug marijuana
there was reefer madness in the 30s
Nixon's war on drugs in the 70s today's
young pot smokers are reluctant to
believe that marijuana is anything but a
harmless herb but today public policy is
starting to catch up to public opinion
on marijuana since California became the
first state to legalize medical
marijuana in 1996 twenty-three states in
the nation's capital have okayed the
plan for medical use four states now
permit recreational use and pot
legalization will be on the ballot and
at least a dozen more this year
these reforms mean patients with
diseases such as cancer and Alzheimer's
can get life-changing treatments violent
drug cartels are being starved and state
and local governments have a new revenue
source to make good on their unfunded
liabilities so it might seem that the
tide of cannabis reform is turned enter
the federal government not only do I not
support legalization of marijuana it is
not the position of the Department of
Justice currently to the feds marijuana
is a schedule 1 substance considered the
most dangerous of the five schedules of
drugs classified by the Controlled
Substances Act of 1970 schedule one
drugs are defined as having a high
potential for abuse and are the only
controlled substances the feds claimed
have no currently accepted medical use
that means the marijuana plan is treated
the same as heroin and is much more
restricted than meth but why does any of
this matter if states are legalizing
marijuana left and right because it
means federal agencies still can and
have ignored state law and rated state
legal facilities on a whim they deny
cannabis businesses access to loans and
bank accounts and perhaps most
perniciously evolved the feds prevent
most scientists from studying
marijuana's medical benefits if it came
out of the Controlled Substances Act and
was treated either entirely differently
or treated more like alcohol or nicotine
not there would be this liberation
around marijuana John hoodak is a senior
fellow at the Brookings Institution who
authored a report that maps out how
marijuana can be moved to a lower drug
schedule that allows medical research or
removed from the schedules entirely
there are two ways that rescheduling can
occur either Congress can do it simply
by passing a law that tends not to
happen the second way involves one
particular man reaching for his pen and
phone
use that pen to sign executive orders
but will he for marijuana what is an
isn't a Schedule one narcotic is a job
for Congress no it's not his
administration can begin the process to
do it the bulk of the power lies with
the Attorney General was appointed by
the president what has to happen first
is the Attorney General has to receive a
petition to reschedule or initiate a
petition on his or her own the FDA then
provides the Attorney General with a
medical and scientific report on
marijuana that recommends a certain
schedule or that it be removed from the
schedules entirely the Attorney General
then looks at FDA's recommendation looks
at the analysis that the Drug
Enforcement Administration has done for
them and then makes a choice in the case
of marijuana that choice has always been
know that Schedule one is proper and
that that's where it will remain and
here's the kicker the feds say marijuana
has to remain in schedule one because
there aren't FDA style clinical studies
supporting its medical value yet such
clinical studies are exactly what the
feds prohibit by keeping marijuana in
schedule one even with this catch-22
there's already abundant evidence of
marijuana's medical value from other
types of studies just ask the Surgeon
General we have some preliminary data
showing that for certain medical
conditions and symptoms that marijuana
can be helpful and if the FDA doesn't
believe the government's own top doc it
should check in with its own parent
agency the Department of Health and
Human Services does hold a patent on
cannabinoids that is the chemical
compounds that make up marijuana the FDA
could even look to its own record it
approved and allowed the rescheduling of
the drug marinol which is just synthetic
THC the primary psychoactive component
of pot and it's given fast-track
approval to sativex a drug derived
directly from marijuana plants the head
of the National Institutes on Drug Abuse
has suggested that we need more research
and we need to reconsider marijuana as a
medicine but none of these admissions
have resulted in any change in federal
law one silver lining is that the Obama
administration which initially rated
more medical marijuana facilities than
even George W Bush has toned down its
war on weed from a peak in 2010
nationally by 2014 marijuana related
arrests were down 18% and the DEA was
seizing 90% less marijuana than it had
been four years earlier that said he
hasn't done enough in the eyes of
reformers there
currently a petition before the Attorney
General to reschedule marijuana but the
time is ticking on the Obama
administration its days in office are
numbered
the most recent petition was brought by
two state governors in 2011 and is still
pending five years later and this is
only the fourth such petition to be
considered since 1972 one took more than
20 years to adjudicate but is there hope
in a future administration one of the
most remarkable things about the 2016
presidential election is that candidates
are talking about pop it's being raised
in terms of prominence it's being raised
in matured as an issue and not as
something that's taboo and I think
that's an important first step the
candidates who we have left at least on
the Democratic side are open to reform
until that happens many veterans will
continue to have to choose between their
pills and their medical cannabis I heard
and I heard from something that I got
right from my country potentially
life-saving medical breakthroughs will
continue to be stifled and anyone who
uses marijuana for any reason will
continue to be vulnerable to a federal
crackdown but as public opinion
continues to shift a future Congress or
POTUS may finally find the political
will to end this modern form of
prohibition and if the high didn't solve
whatever it was that was getting you
down it could at least help you laugh at
the world's ongoing folly and see
through all the hypocrisy and [__]
and cheap moralism MP
[Music]